we saw that we could take a system of
two equations with two unknowns
and represent it as a matrix equation
where the matrix
a is are the coefficients here on the
left hand side
the column vector x has our two unknown
variables
s and t and then the column vector b is
essentially representing the right hand
side over here
and what was interesting about it well
then that would be the equation a the
matrix a times the column vector x being
equal to the column vector b
and what was interesting about that is
we saw well look if a is invertible we
can multiply
both the both the left and the right
hand sides of the equation and we have
to multiply them on the left-hand sides
of their respective sides by a
inverse because remember matrix when
matrix multiplication order matters so
we're multiplying the left-hand side
of both sides of the equation if we do
that then we can get
to essentially solving for the unknown
column vector if we know what column
vector x is then we know what
s and t are and then we've essentially
solved the system of equations
so now let's actually do that let's
actually figure out what a
inverse is and multiply that times the
column vector b to figure out what
the column vector x is and and what s
and t are
so a inverse a inverse
is equal to 1 over the determinant of a
the determinant of a it for a for a 2 by
2 here is going to be
2 times 4 minus negative 2
times negative 5. so it's going to be 8
minus positive 10 8 minus positive 10
which would be negative 2.
so this would become negative 2 right
over here once again 2 times 4 is 8
minus negative 2 times negative 5. so
minus
positive 10 which gets us negative 2
and you multiply 1 over the determinant
times
what is sometimes called the adjoint of
a
which is essentially swapping the top
left and bottom right or at least for a
two by two matrix
so this would be a four this would be a
two notice i just swap these and making
these two negative
the negative of what they already are so
this is from a negative 2 that's going
to become a positive 2
and this right over here is going to
become a positive 5. if all of this
looks completely unfamiliar to you
you might want to review the tutorial on
inverting
matrices because that's all i'm doing
here and so a
inverse is going to be equal to
a inverse is going to be equal to
let's see this is negative one half
times four
is negative two negative one half
negative one half times five
is negative two point five negative
two point five and
negative one half times two is negative
one
negative one half times two is negative
one so that's a inverse right over here
so now let's multiply a inverse times
our column vector
seven negative six so let's do that so
this is a inverse i'll rewrite it
negative
2 negative 2.5 negative 1
negative 1 times 7
and negative 6 times i'll just write
them all in white here now
7 negative 6. we've had a lot of
practice multiplying
multiplying matrices so what is this
going to be equal to
so the first entry is going to be
negative 2 times 7
which is negative 14
plus negative 2.5
times negative 6. so let's see that's
going to be positive
that's going to be 12 plus another 3 so
it's going to be plus 15
plus 15. negative 2.5
times negative 6 is positive 15.
and then we're going to have negative 1
times 7 which is negative 7
plus negative 1 times negative 6. well
that is
positive 6. and so our
the product a inverse b which is the
same thing as a column vector x
is equal to we deserve a little bit of a
drum roll now the column vector 1
negative 1. so we have just shown that
this
is equal to 1 negative 1
or that x is equal to 1 negative 1
or we could even say that the column
vector
a column vector st
s column vector with the entries s and t
is equal to is equal to
1 negative 1 is equal to
1 negative 1 which is another way of
saying that s
is equal to 1 and t is equal to negative
1.
and i know what you're saying i said
this in the last video and i'll say it
again in this video you're like well you
know it was so much easier to to solve
the system
directly just with using elimination or
using substitution and i agree with you
but it is this is a useful technique
because when you are doing
problems in computation there may be
situations where you have the left hand
side of the system is
stays the same but there's many many
many different values for the right hand
side of the system
and so it might be easier to just
compute the inverse once
and just keep multiplying keep
multiplying this inverse times the
different
the what we have on the right-hand side
and you know you probably are familiar
with you know some types of you know you
have graphics processors and graphics
cards on computers and they talk about
special graphic
processors what these are really all
about are the hardware
that is special purpose for really fast
matrix multiplication
because when you're doing graphics
processing when you're thinking about
modeling things in three dimensions and
you're doing all these transformations
you're really just doing a lot of matrix
multiplications really really really
fast in real time so that to the user
playing the game or whatever they're
doing
it feels like they're in some type of a
you know 3d real-time reality
so anyway i just want to point that out
this wouldn't be you know if i
if if the if i saw this just randomly my
instincts would
be to solve this with elimination but
this this
ability to think of this as a as a
matrix equation
is is a very very useful concept
one actually not just in computation but
also as you go into higher level
sciences especially physics you will see
a lot of
matrix vector equations like this that
kind of speak in generalities and it's
really important to think about what
these actually represent
and how they can actually be solved